[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance aren't these people high or
what the Department of Education whose
new secretary Betsy DeVos begins her
term acting like she has never had any
education tweets out a salute to the
author and activist w eb du bois by
misspelling his name Department of
Education then hours later issues its
apologies and misspells apologies are
these people hi or what on Instagram
Trump commemorates Abraham Lincoln's
birthday and the GOP does the same on
Twitter by posting this photo and
attributing that quote to the great
present the first printed record of that
quote actually comes from an
advertisement for a book about aging
published in 1947 82 years after Lincoln
died are these people high or what Trump
in a private meeting with senators of
both parties to talk about his Supreme
Court nominee wanders off into his
mental woods again calls Elizabeth
Warren Pocahontas again and tells the ex
senator Kelly Ayotte that she would have
kept her seat in New Hampshire but for
thousands of illegal votes cast there by
people bussed in from Massachusetts are
these people hi or what New Hampshire's
former Republican chairman offers $1,000
for proof of just one such illegal bust
in vote a Federal Elections Commissioner
appointed by President George HW Bush
demands Trump share his proof quote with
the appropriate law enforcement
authorities so that his allegations may
be investigated promptly and thoroughly
whereupon Trump's propagandist flavor of
the month Stephen Miller goes on
television and offers as proof no proof
I've actually having worked before in a
campaign in New Hampshire I can tell you
that this issue of busing voters into
New Hampshire is widely known by anyone
who's worked in New Hampshire politics
it's very real it's very serious this
morning on this show is not the venue
for me to lay out all the evidence
translation you want proof I offer is
proof my opinion because there is no
proof
are these people high or what Public
Policy Polling asks 712 voters do you
agree or disagree with the following
statement the bowling-green Massacre
shows why we need Donald Trump's
executive order on immigration roughly
51 percent of Trump voters answer yes
the Muslim ban is justified by the
bowling-green massacre there is no
Bowling Green massacre this is the same
nonsense that Kellyanne Conway made up
are these people high or what last
August the same pollster asked would you
support or oppose building a wall along
the Atlantic Ocean to keep Muslims from
entering the country from the Middle
East 31 percent of those identifying
themselves at Trump supporters said yes
to walling off the entire eastern
seaboard to keep out Muslims coming in
by surfboard or submarine or swimming
here from Baghdad are these people high
or what again same pollster asking do
you think Donald Trump should be able to
overturn decisions by judges that he
disagrees with or not 51% said yes
another 16 percent of Trump supporters
aren't sure only a third of Trump
supporters said no a democracy in which
the president can overturn the rulings
of judges is not a democracy it is a
dictatorship a majority of Trump voters
are okay with replacing key parts of the
United States of America with one-man
rule are these people high or what and
when all of these threads of madness
join up and the immigration history of
this country has betrayed by a would-be
tyrant looking for scapegoats the
picture changes from Americans acting as
if intoxicated and becomes Americans
acting just like ordinary Germans did
under the Nazis or just as ordinary
Russians did under the Communists JFK
Airport an Iraqi woman detained 33 hours
handcuffed reportedly denied a
wheelchair she'd come here to see her
son her son a sergeant in the American
82nd Airborne Division at Fort Bragg
Philadelphia International
a woman flies in from Iran to see her
daughters both American doctoral
students her passport is seized somehow
she doesn't seem to have her cell phone
anymore Customs puts her on another
flight back to Iran they couldn't tell
her daughters which flight Frankfurt
Germany American customs there keeps dr.
Samira Ascari from flying to Boston
where the next day she was supposed to
start her fellowship at the Harvard med
school Dulles Airport woman traveling
with two citizen children reportedly
detained for 20 hours without food told
the kids could stay but she would be
deported to Africa handcuffed even when
going to the bathroom bush
intercontinental Houston man coming in
from Chile reportedly forced to give his
phone to customs to give them the pin
number for the phone to authorize them
to copy the phone's contents he is a
scientist at the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory the phone belongs to his
employer NASA he works for an arm of the
US government he was born in the US and
back at Dulles five-year-old boy US
citizen kept from his mother detained
for four hours Sean Spicer's reaction
quote to assume that just because of
someone's age or gender whatever that
they don't pose a threat would be
misguided and wrong are these people
high or what last month as I sat next to
him on his set my friend Bill Maher
managed to do something he had not done
since 1978 he shocked me
he cited statistics that the 14 states
in this country with the highest number
of painkiller prescriptions per person
all voted last November for Trump and
where Trump did the best West Virginia
an average of roughly 433 pain pills per
person over the last six years in that
state 80% of the states that the
greatest heroin use went for Trump six
of the nine Ohio counties Trump flipped
from Obama had opioid overdose rates
high above the national average all of
the ones he flipped in Pennsylvania have
nearly doubled the Nash
overdose rate madness surrounds us in
the government in the behavior of its
spokespeople in the a morality and
brutality of those who enforce its
decrees and in the rising disinterest in
democracy of those who support this man
so once more much more solemnly are
these people high or what resist peace